et bien sûr dans l'instant locales et la
question c'est que vous l'avez
s'endettant 17 merci alors oui comment
il va se suicider vous merci très bien
on la fuit depuis lequel rebelles
n'avaient pas envie de chercher des
noises
[Rires]
non sur quoi consacré à la révélation
touche pas à mon poste année sa
spécialité c'est donner des dragons pas
autant pas en remontant pas donc voilà
donc donc dis moi ce que tu veux dire le
plaisir la spécialité la spécialité
s'est donné des dates c'est bon c'est
sûr une personne qui adore donner des
dates et parler de star décédée je veux
bien sûr parler de fabien lecoeuvre
le bernard montiel ne peut jamais le cas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
celle de voyage pour faire du tellement
drôle alors mon enquête ce soir c'est
fabien lecoeuvre est il le plus grand
chroniqueur de l'histoire de tpm pea
après rachid arhab lui c'est le meilleur
ami des stars décédées plus connu sous
le nom de fabien lecoeuvre
il est également l'ami des stars les
plus en vue du moment tels qu henri
guybet jeanne mance on ou encore emile
de emile et images
il est alors logique qu'il ait reçu il
ya 17 jours sms sur son smartphone
dernière génération dont ce message
écrit par cyril hanouna frérot et vient
avec ou âme dans la grande barca et tpm
p on va kiffer de ouf
mon poto bien entendu à ce message
fabien lecoeuvre ne comprend rien que
dalle ou encore ou à louer
heureusement un ami maghrébins lui
traduit et pour sa première il est
accueilli à bras ouverts depuis son
arrivée dans touche pas à mon poste
fabien lecoeuvre marche sur l'eau en
deux semaines il a déjà fait plus
d'émissions que françois viaud en disant
alors fabien lecoeuvre est il le plus
grand chroniqueur de l'histoire de tpm
paix après rachid arhab qui est vraiment
le meilleur ami de fabien lecoeuvre
patrick chêne thomas dutronc ou gilles
bouleau et surtout après michel
polnareff fabien lecoeuvre aurait-il la
chance de devenir l'attaché de presse de
mohamed benyamna plus connu sous le nom
de bouder autant question aucun
inspecteur la barre va tenter de les
calmer
mais c'est vrai le grand chroniqueur
depuis très longtemps franchement sexy
là il va marquer sur l'époque celui qui
a way et je vais continuer un peu sur le
fabuleux car il sait tout sur tout les
stars même les stars qui sont pas encore
des stars comme dans son bus quittent
par exemple parce que il expliquait sa
théorie la semaine dernière sur les
petits chanteurs qui mue quand ils
grandissent et essayer sa théorie ça
faisait un petit peu estomaqué comme
disent les jeunes
un petit peu estomaqué tout de suite
c'est au nouveau look baba
[Musique]
cette mission restait des carrières
dangereuse quand on est enfant comme ça
parce qu'avec la mue pour les garçons
selon ces les testicules descendent ou
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi c'est un animateur
hors pair
enfin bien sûr il avait 1000 villes 1000
émissions et bien sûr 1000 femmes
est ce que j'aime chez lui c'est sa
capacité à vraiment raconter tout ce
qu'on appelle en jargon ses frasques
ouais c'est vrai c'est frais c'est
incroyable et vos frasques bas jamais
vous avez fait que des taux de souffre
c'est incroyable notamment à vos belles
mères et à vos nouveaux au nouveau
fiancé 2 ex oui c'est incroyable à
tendance qui racontait la s'est réalisée
par un professionnel ou tentez pas de
faire pareil à la maison voici les
histoires extraordinaires de benjamin
castaldi
les histoires extraordinaires de
benjamin castaldi
benjamin castaldi a une très belle façon
d'accueillir le nouveau fiancé de sa 23e
ex-fn je savais qu'il y avait bien un
avocat oued et buvait de la vodka un peu
en bray gros avantage de cette vodka
selon fait pipi dedans pas trop ça reste
le jaune dont je tous les jours je vais
un petit pipi de dents dont tous les
jours il a vu largement je pense qu'on
durée et après et le serait alors il
paraît qu'il a beaucoup grandi
benjamin castaldi a une façon très
particulière d'utiliser la brosse à
dents du nouveau fiancé de sa 23e ex
femme qui me rendait fou je voyais ça
[ __ ] brosse à dents et à chaque fois
que je pourrais jouer ce brosse à dents
je la prenais un an et je me brosse est
intégralement la nu non en été et on
remettait le supra nu benjamin castaldi
a une façon très particulière de
cuisiner
surtout quand il reçoit son ex belle
maman une fois l'effet des huîtres à la
maison tu as les aimait pas fait 18,7
dans comme avec j'ai changé un petit peu
de produits pas cracher dedans non non
pire que ça alors j'ai tout bien
préparés comme à l'aimer et bien été un
petit peu pas beaucoup un donné stop
comme ça ça
à
je préfère ma relation avec mon ex
belle-mère obama n'a jamais été
constitué c'étaient les histoires
extraordinaires de benjamin castaldi
[Musique]
vous
alors ce soir c'est le retour de valence
ton post ligne assurant avec la mémoire
qui sera en direct ce sera dans un
instant je vous dis et ce sera la
dernière fois qui va parler de toutes
les polémiques
sa dernière télé sur ça ce sera btp vous
dit et il va nous faire aussi de grosses
révélations sur son avenir c'est très
très très attendu ça fera face à
l'équipe de balances ton post ce sera à
21h15 exactement que c'est l'émission on
vous découvre un petit peu rendez vous
vous êtes pas seulement spéciale de la
barca est aussi un spécialiste
géopolitique c'est ça qui est très fort
et comme j'ai rien à faire en ce moment
j'ai revu la première ne touche pas à
mon poste sur des 8es pendant la
chronique de philippe vandel mais 457
prédécesseur je me suis rendu compte
qu'une star de balances ton poste était
déjà là dans dés la première sur des
beats vous assure que oui regardez vous
étiez un petit peu faute chez lui et
vous êtes moquer de lui un pub c'est pas
cool c'est incroyable et la personne en
question va trouver ça scandaleux
regardez avec son lot qui on valoir
avec son look et ses regrets tout droit
sortie d'un film sur la mafia pas du
tout c'est parce que vous croyez
ils dénoncent la corruption des forces
de police il est conseiller municipal de
marseille députée européenne d'europe
écologie les verts jamais vu un écolo
comme savon car il sera là bien sûr dans
un instant rien sur laon pour s'endormir
bernamont tiennent ils compte le nombre
de point soleil qui est déjà visité mois
de m'endormir je compte au nom de prise
de parole et chroniqueurs vous savez
prévoir un peu le rapport qualité prix
de chacun la semaine dernière c'était
mathieu delormeau qu'avait plus parler
est ce qu'il a construit sa place de
numéro 1 c'est le classement
n'oubliez pas de prendre la parole
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre nouvelle
édition de n'oubliez pas de prendre la
parole le classement le plus sexy du paf
angers
aïe
on commence avec la dernière position en
deux en tant que dj tels n'a passé que
trop de neuf disques et 39 c'est
justement le nombre d'interventions
cette semaine qu'ils vivent est devenue
la nouvelle stéphane bern
[Musique]
à l'époque de halloween on off rêvait
citrouille à la 9e place on retrouve
celui qui s'est marié tellement de fois
qu'il a passé plus de temps à l'église
que sur un plateau télé seulement
quarante et une prise de parole pour
benjamin castaldi
j'ai tenu 86 jours 12 mois 2 ans j'avais
12 ans sans coucher mais à quel âge en
haut du classement il perd sa place de
leader dans cette semaine mettez de
l'orb admirateurs homosexuels 88
intervention pour l'ancien animateur de
ouf
[Applaudissements]
je pense que dans un lit vous êtes une
queen il retrouve donc sa place sur le
trône gauche il est le seul à avoir cru
que cyril hanouna deviendrait vraiment
le valet des chroniqueurs 98
intervention bonjour michel même si je
perds ce match aujourd'hui je démarrais
toutes les émissions par dire bonsoir à
vous mes patrons si tu as l'air du large
comme les cheminots nyon et on se quitte
avec une info média capital
battu de longs mois le cul à la semaine
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr comme à chaque fin de chronique
tendre dévoilé celui qui a le plus
tacler ses collègues et devant donc ça
fait dix-sept fois que vous remporter le
trophée d'affilée 7 à dire cette fois
déjà alors je pense déjà tout de suite
et la musique de suspense cette semaine
en grèce à des versements égaux victoire
était moins la tristesse indiquent
séance à chaque fois alors est ce que
gagner une dixième fois une septième
fois ce serait vraiment une consécration
d'autres car oui c'est vrai oui cette
semaine
on ne va pas
cc
[Applaudissements]
coût 25 minutes de dahouët si si je vous
assure que j'ai fait une minute c'est
pas à la barbade c'est au départ je vais
faire comme seul épisode avec marie
nataf et puis finalement ils m'ont gardé
dix ans à la c70
ah ouais bah ouais mon cas il ya 20 ans
il avait vraiment annoncé la mort d'une
actrice et ça c'était pas une erreur
kennedy est mort en berne et oui oui
bref je me rappelle on avait fait une
fête de ouf qui dormait en taule à la
couarde or bien quoi tu deviens toi tu
dois te y entend les bébés sont
seulement celles c'est vrai ouais mais
bon c'est avec la célébrité eason ça
m'étonne pas c'est que quand on arrive
[Applaudissements]
ça vient d'où un e égal mc2 c'est la
vitesse la vitesse du navire est un
objet qui chutent n'importe quoi juste
ta carrière
mam francs
[Applaudissements]